[Music]
we are live with the stars of the
neighborhood you like my enthusiasm I'm
trying to pick this up today Beth and
Max thanks you guys so much for being
here we've got episode 5 coming tonight
game night and it's a great episode what
can you tease about what we can expect
tonight it's a really good episode they
we the Johnsons come over for game night
at the butler's house and Calvin is like
you know king of game night so there's
obviously tension and comedy that ensues
and we've heard that they're gamers too
yep and we try to bring our games over
into some big trouble reveal something
we discover some things as we start
playing these games and some truth comes
out truth comes out and we try to amend
some truth it's good it's actually
really it's an awesome episode tonight
you you tweeted this was one of your
favorite episodes of television ever to
shoot why he didn't have many scenes
with me they're equally as favorite but
this one just because I got to get
Cinnabons over and over again and also
uh that we get to do some physical
comedy me and Tichina at the mall that
um
it's like my favorite anytime I get to
do a physical scene it's it's always so
funny with her I mean she's a mess so
it's a good one how many Cinnabons did
you eat it full disclosure it was not
that many I think it was one full one
because I had halves oh that's a big
though they're big and it was because I
wouldn't just order how many men
normally you could eat if you have an
hour I think I have an hour yeah I feel
like I could I could put away like six I
really don't know about you I'd say to
come in an hour
like you pick me pace it out if I'm
starving but they're big girl I mean you
know cuz I just
Ethan I was like yeah I want to like
Joey Chestnut these things it was the
little gun to my head I say six two but
then I die
he has a great Jenga moment
in this episode chillin I love a good
chain a moment jiangha moments are good
but I'm stuck on the Cinnabons I think I
die I put down a 6-pack of Siemens
everyone pays so healthy he never has
sugar carbs or anything so good I look
at him
well I tried I try to keep it clean keep
it clean and classy clean and classy so
since we are start taking the episode
off with game night who among you is the
most competitive who's more competitive
you're very competitive I'm competitive
are you you don't seem like you'd be
competitive I'm quietly competitive but
like I'm competitive more with myself
right I like to pretend I don't care so
that if I lose I'm like oh well but I
care so much
oh I don't pretend I care especially at
game night I got kicked out of a game
night in college because I got so angry
hungry oh no I totally cheated but the
word or whatever and I was like and I
think I was like take a lot it's so mad
I don't like to lose at sports again I
know I'm not here's here's why I'm not
very competitive
specifically with games is that um I
refuse to listen to directions ok would
drive me nuts so when somebody's
describing how a game works I'm just
like and then the game starts and I
realized I don't have play and then I
just sort of black out for a while okay
he's not invited to our game night no I
wanted I was playing Trivial Pursuit in
college and I didn't know a very simple
answer and then the guy made fun of me
and I was like I'm done
and you came over yes whoa oh that's
good yeah I'm a bored flipper I'm not
like a little drama in my game night
okay well I want to back up just to the
show in general because you two played
very well-known sitcom characters for so
long was there any apprehension to sign
on to another sitcom and wasn't
important to find characters that were
unlike men Caroline I'd say yes on both
of our harder so that branch and to jump
into a new show what made it appealing
is
doing it together yeah that was the
reason I signed on when he signed on you
know cuz I wasn't gonna maybe do another
multi can yes and I and I think
initially for me having Cedric and
Tichina already in place was like okay
great family cuz we got to see the pilot
with Marcel and shyam - and it was so
yeah but having them and knowing like oh
this isn't gonna like fall on my
shoulders this is gonna be an ensemble
and then having Beth comment you're like
oh this is this really feels like an
incredible situation alright so fun when
in front of the live audience and it's
you know there's something about
multicam that I grew up on that I love I
love being there every day yeah so much
fun it is truly like the most fun acting
job I think you can have all right and
you guys do know each other from before
you were yeah hello my name is Doris
together did that do you think that
helped you get a hundred I mean it was
like there wasn't even any ease because
I mean we became friends after that I
still have my vacation ones like Texaco
and yeah we we've been friends for a
while so it was really easy and fun to
come in and said you're conditioned and
everybody welcomed us with open arms and
awesome it's very easy for us to play a
married couple well the show has a lot
of heart in it certainly doesn't back
away from from tackling issues what kind
of conversations do you guys have on set
before filming those moments to make
sure it's you know handled properly it's
such a pain in the ass so I'm sure we
like I think what the joke on set as I
can't believe we decided to make a show
that's about something it takes it's
like everywhere it really is about
representation and about hearing voices
and Jim Reynolds who created the show
who runs our writers room and there's a
showrunner man he has the approach that
he has taken is to really be open to
everyone's input and that's a lot that's
like an aggressive stance for a
showrunner to take right and to his
credit he's been incredible with it and
really sort of listened to everybody and
understand and is understanding that you
know that's what this show is it's about
everybody's point of view and
understanding people's point of view and
how they differ
and like I'm so excited for people to
see tonight's episode too because it
does have those moments of heart but
then it like ends with one of the
funniest jokes I've seen in this I come
but I can't say anything but there's a
joke about a game it's really funny
[Laughter]
what's the what's like the real version
I guess it's there is a real version I
think it's based on I'm not totally sure
Ryan rabbits is one of our writers like
the game that we play on the show might
be real and he might be like I can't
believe they think it's fake but it's
sort of I think it's porn
based on Settlers of Catan so imagine I
I met I could be where I thought there
was one I don't want to give away the
joke but I thought there was one that
really did take place there and the day
which such a game nerd told me about
yeah I mean it's real nerds well
speaking of tubercles and new girl are
there any former co-stars you would like
to see pop up as guest stars and have
those conversations been happening at
all you know what I would love to see
Jennifer Coolidge and I feel like it
would probably be the funniest scene on
television yeah yeah yeah I really want
a little more into doing it so much I
think like the show he's meant to be on
yeah but it's gotta be the right role
we've talked about although like it's
got a way to you know the problem is is
we have such a strong cast and it's and
it's deep so I mean guest stars are sort
of few and far between especially in the
first season so you want to wait for
like a really good moment to get some of
these guys that you want to waste it
yeah it's about other shows that just
have guest stars rolling in and yeah
hopefully we get hopefully we get that
many seasons where at some point I like
you know now it's just about because I'm
not bringing against the guest stars
well how like we're on Episode five at
this point how is the show already
evolved since the pilot and where would
you like to see it go in the future
mm-hmm well I think the really nice part
about the show is is that it involved
quickly you know the first two episodes
I think specifically has us moving into
this neighborhood and being on our best
behavior and you know just yeah just
walking on eggshells and sort of like oh
I'm sorry and that was the that was the
extent of the comedy that we were sort
of were loud to play and now that we're
more comfortable and these two families
are now living next to each other
permanently it allows to open it up and
I think as the show move sometime they
get more and more comfortable with one
another and that's where you really
expose the flaws of these characters and
where it becomes funny right and then it
becomes about you know less about race
and more about these two families yeah
just normal day-to-day life but you know
what you would really have with your
neighbors kind of thing in a friendship
and and yeah it's cool and it's been fun
to see like the as it's evolved we've
seen like Marty's character you get to
know some of them the characters deeper
to which has been really really cool
yeah and we haven't cover a little bit
of your past in this episode yeah Gemma
Gemma's dark
that's hot got a charlie by the way when
you guys why just really go wow it's
gonna get dark so say dark gritty Star
Trek is involved I can say that yes that
is true for everybody we're really we're
really asking these headlines here so
what can you tease for the rest of the
season after tonight as well there's an
episode we have that actually goes into
sort of Gemma and Dave's relationship a
little deeper and he has one of the
funniest moments I think he's had so far
in that episode I don't want to ruin it
but Tom Cruise is involved um bats are
really great when coming up him and
Cedric have one the one we just shot
with you guys on the bus kids like one
of my favorites oh god you guys had all
that and then yeah there's just a lot
coming up those involved and he was not
a special guest star joint your star we
have a Star Trek cross tell everybody
yeah I mean look we we just got picked
up for a full seasons yeah I don't
totally know where I don't anybody knows
where we're going for the rest of the
season yeah but but again you know it'd
be there's that comfortability with
these two neighbors that have moved next
to each other where you're like okay
here it gets it just gets more
comfortable and and and better I think
because of that yeah as we move on yeah
and you guys have like a neighborly bond
with Cedric and and you know we're all
it's such a family it's like an instant
family to be honest it took no no work
yeah it's like no one's like nervous
about what it's like to be on a TV show
that's what's sort of nice about it you
have like Tichina who's been doing this
forever
Cedric obviously Beth and I who come
from these two shows it's like this is
very everybody there's nothing like is
new Danny Yeah right we're just there to
do the work we know how to do it and
because of that it's a very loose
environment which allows it yeah in the
audience you know it's fun it's like a
really fun environment you on tape night
yeah like Cedric I might as well forget
their lines yeah who forgets their lines
the most no not you I think no well I am
i everybody I'll get caught a lot where
I'm like when I have less lines it's
harder for me yeah English is love it
when you mess up that's their favorite
Wiles yeah no live TV those are the feel
for that stuff if you watch it on TV
that's a good way to look at it exactly
I think they get scared though when I do
it cuz I think I did break for the first
time in a scene and could not keep it
together the other name of Tichina
ourselves no I tried it our crew guys
like we saw you but I mean I tried so
hard not to laugh but it was so funny
that like my my cheeks were like shaking
because I couldn't
but they can't leave I blew it do you
ever see that when you're watching the
show but yeah oh I'm with Jennifer
Coolidge like I would you could see me
like almost like trying so hard to be
like smiling yeah this one this one's
pretty good I got I'm your guy why you I
used to break on new girls so much but
that was only because truly I was with
the wildest group of people yeah and
nobody was on nobody would say the words
that were written and it became this is
much later on but it became who could
make the other person without saying and
and I lost
oh well thank you guys so much I look
forward to the rest of the night's
episode thank you guys so much for
watching
[Music]